>> You've gotten feedback
based on your responses and
we hope you take it seriously.
There are two options for what happened.
In option one, one or more of those
feedback messages said that now isn't
the right time for
you to begin this NIM degree.
Maybe you don't have some background
knowledge, but you can get it.
>> And once you get it,
you will be ready.
And remember, even once you
are ready to start the program,
there still will be
challenges along the way.
>> Exactly.
And option two is that you are ready.
And if you decide to make this
commitment, there's a good chance that
in a matter of months, your career
will be drastically different.
But even if you're ready and
you do make the commitment,
this will still be challenging.
>> Mm-hm.
It's perfectly possible that over the
next several months, you'll have times
where things feel challenging or you
feel frustrated, you feel overwhelmed or
maybe you even feel like you
don't belong in this program.
>> I wouldn't even say
perfectly possible.
I would say, very probable.
And those things are going to
happen when your code won't run and
you don't know why or
you feel lost in intimidating
jargon that you don't understand.
Or when you're trying to install
software and it won't run or
someone in the forum
is way ahead of you.
>> When these things happen, understand
that they happen to everybody.
>> Right.
And some of that struggle is
unavoidable and actually productive.
It's just what learning feels like.
>> Mm-hm.
And in those moments
when you're struggling,
it's important to remember too that you
have a whole community of your fellow
students out there to help you.
As well as your team of
Udacity coaches here.
>> And Google.
>> Yes, Google.
Amazing resource.
Definitely figure out how to
answer your own questions.
>> But not all of the struggle
with the productive kind.
Sometimes, it will be
because we made a mistake.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And we're constantly learning and
improving too.
So maybe our instructions
weren't clear or
maybe we assumed something
we shouldn't have.
>> Mm-hm.
When you're struggling,
be sure to let us know.
So like Andy said,
we can learn from your feedback.
Because that's,
that's how we learn how to improve.
>> Right.
The,
the bottom line is there will
be times when this is hard.
But if you persevere, you will succeed.
>> Whatever you choose to learn next and
however you choose to learn it,
remember that for
every obstacle you encounter,
you'll be able to do amazing
new things as a result of it.